hi good afternoon I'm Subbaiah venkata
senior manager at Google I'm happy to be
here with you today
let's get started we are going to talk
about seamlessly migrating your networks
on workloads into GCP so what is the
agenda next slide
so we have three speakers here today I'm
Saba I'm going to talk about why and how
you should migrate your networks into
GCP then Ines is going to talk about
specific use cases and service model
then the concluding remarks and hybrid
use cases talked by Amit
so why you should migrate your workloads
into Google compute engine what is
special about it what are the advantages
of Google compute engine if there is
anything you want to take out today this
is the slide you should remember this is
the one slide we captured everything
Google networks are great the
performance is amazing we can get 14
gbps through port single zone VM to VM
similarly we can give 100 microseconds
round-trip latency VM to VM single zone
this is very amazing we will talk about
how we are able to actually achieve this
high throughput and low latency in the
next slide coming to how fast you can
actually bring up Williams in Google
clock you can bring up like one VM to M
up 2,000 plus VMs thousands of VMs you
can bring in a couple of minutes
an average three to five minutes you can
have thousand VMs up and running third
network performance you can have we
implemented a seamless hitless upgrades
offer in Ross structure that includes
kernels our hypervisors software defense
tag so many components without having
any kind of network performance
degradation for the VMS we were able to
do that be
and the since migration of vm's a bid
the stack and muda vm's back in second
global network it is not just the GCL
big global wave it's much more than that
from the beginning we designed an
architecture a networking stack with a
global view in mind that means you can
create a virtual network in any zone
multiple zones across regions thousands
of themes you can scatter them in all
the different zones you can have high
throughput and high latency last one is
network functions as service who has
spent last year entire DCP 320 plus
features and functions networking alone
we have tens of features and functions
we implemented in one year thanks to our
great design and architecture of
Software Defined Networking stack we are
able to channel features so fast
now we have all the necessary and
sufficient functions for you to migrate
your workloads and networks with a
Google Cloud
those include networks virtual networks
sub networks it's trippy load balancing
HTTP load balancing TCP load balancing
UDP load balancing cloud DNS cloud CDN
cloud VPN cloud router so on and so
forth we'll talk about all these
different categories next let's step
back I talked about getting at what 14
Gbps of throughput and 100 microseconds
of latency this is not possible in a day
or a week or even years if you look at
the Google's history Google has spent
decade or so class of innovation
perseverance a lot of money resources to
spend and meticulously designing the
network Google networks are amazing this
is a good example where you can see that
we publish papers in seminole sitcoms
and repeated journals in 2013 we
published a paper in before van traffic
engineering this is a groundbreaking
paper on first of its kind to do
software-defined networking at a global
scale of a van network
similarly we published a paper in 2015
second about how we architecture our
software defining clusters we started
with five host clusters in 2005 and
watched our clusters in 2008 2012
certain clusters finally in Jupiter
clusters all of these are available
published in a paper called Jupiter
rising these Jupiter clusters are
fantastic latency very high throughput
than anyone in the world then in 2014 we
published a blog post about Andromeda
and ramírez stack
covers all of googles compute engine
networking stack with this Sdn
architecture for Andromeda it's possible
for us to implement features any kinds
of features not just external features
internal features including isolation
encryption encapsulation all of these
features are possible because our design
of Andromeda to recap you can see that
we have software-defined van we have
software different clusters finally we
have software-defined cloud virtual
networks because of that it's possible
to see and get like very high throughput
and very low latency we are not going to
stop there over the years
we are going to see amazing results
because of these investments so let's
step back and look at
what are the different cloud networking
tools and functions available we
categorize them after listening to you
into four different categories the
faceook the fundamental first building
block is our virtual networks as we
discussed you can create virtual
networks virtual machines containers
across the globe crossing different
regions in a single API then last year
we released more granular sub networks
you can group a set of IP addresses VMs
or containers in the sub granular group
by zone or by region we'll get to how
the sub networks IP addressing the
naming works in the next slide coming to
the second point
what about control people ask we would
like to see the control and security
control is very important how can as an
organization trust certain individual
get access to manipulate the resources
certain people actually get to change
certain people get only view the
resources we have given a couple of
networking
I am functionalities called Network
admin role network a user role security
admin role and instance admin role for I
am which is in beta right now and then
once you have the control setup how
about the firewalls I would like to
ensure the security of my networks which
VM is supposed to talk to each other VM
I need a control then we have the
firewall solution you can get up to
hundred firewalls rules with very
granular scale or very microscopic scale
you can configure them based on
reputation you can get even more
firewall rules these firewall rules are
both at l3 level and l4 level and you
can actually apply them at the name
target name or IP range level the global
scale for web serving applications we
delivered all necessary load balancing
features like SSL load balancing TC
P UDP load balancing its repeal or
balancing hdbut s load balancing DNS and
cloud CDN these two sir is sufficient
for you to click on few buttons in the
UI and actually deploy your web serving
applications as the previous talks
talked about the final one is hybrid
offerings if you wanted to partially
move your application to Google Cloud
you want to extend out you want to scale
out your on-premise sites into Google
Cloud we have three different products
cloud VPN you have Lu IPSec VPN switch
does 1.5 Gbps per tunnel we'll talk
about that later and then we have cloud
router functionality where you can be GP
for bgp functionality to dynamically
learn the topologies and learn about the
changes between entre my search and
Google compute engine
the final one we have is cloud
interconnect you can connect directly to
us or two through a carrier exchange
this entire set of features is now
sufficient necessary for you to migrate
to Google flower we'll see how we use
all of these features to migrate your
workloads let's step back and see an
example architecture before we migrate
like a couple of use cases how does the
all this thing fit together visually for
example you have a start of an
organization I would like to see how all
of this fit together think that on the
left hand side you have Google global
network though physical network in
different regions and each region has
zones in other side you have an
organization set up where you have given
certain privileges to certain
individuals then the network admin comes
along in the UI he just creates with few
button clicks a virtual network and then
he divides the virtual networks into sub
networks another few button clicks it's
available you can create up to hundreds
of sub networks in a particular region
and then security admin console long
with a different I am role hey I'm a
security admin
I would like to secure your sub-networks
on VMC in this fashion for example say
that only one sub-networks get access
the private in public internet rest of
the sub networks are not supposed to
access the Internet
all of this is possible through security
firewall rules and then come so long
service accounts who have enabled
service accounts so that you can access
Google Cloud Storage API
other Google services with a specific
that means specific only VMs and
applications can use our Google services
you can do that through service accounts
this is also another form of security
then Network admin comes along creates
cloudiness and start serving through
load balancing that you have seen before
then you want to see that oh no actually
I have a couple of compromised data
centers I would like to connect them
then you know one of the sub networks in
one of the regions you bring up cloud
VPN and cloud router functionality and
start connecting to your optimized data
centers very securely through IPSec
tunnels this is all the building blocks
some of them are for example missing but
you can visualize this cloud
interconnect and how this works this is
how the networking model we are
concerned and design this is a global
scale one let's look at how is IP
addressing IP addressing or naming are
very fundamental for networking if you
have to get this right so we have spent
a lot of amount of time talking to
customers talking to you getting the
input to see actually how can we provide
a seamless migration for you the
movement you go into the cloud console
and create an account for Google create
the project you get a default network
you don't have to create any network we
call it default network is pre created
for you inside the default Network
we create auto mode sub networks we have
two different modes of sub networks we
create by auto mode we pre create one
sub network in every region these are
non or
Bing non-contiguous different ranges we
pick the hardest thing range for you you
don't how to know what is addressing for
you then you come along say I'm a power
user I don't want you to create actually
autumn or subnetworks I want to create
many such sub networks for example you
may say that each of my service I wanted
a sub Network maybe group of my services
I wanted a sub network you can do that
you can create up to 400 such sub
networks in a network you can see in one
of the region's we have two sub networks
there are more than they're more
advantageous or customer sub networks
you can bring in your own private
address space at a Google Cloud
we have no restrictions you can bring in
the entire RFC 1988 in space for you RFC
1918 space consists of three different
networks 10/8 one 17 16 / 12 mm /
to use then we have a flexible
allocation model you don't have to
create contiguous of networks you can
create very random sub networks from the
IP space as much as 100 for sub networks
you can create with reputation actually
can increase the sub networks - and
these are expandable that's very key
important for example you created a sub
network range / / 20/24 let's say the
number of beams increased because of
your node increased with a click of a
button you can change the subnet works
you can increase it from / 20 photo /
quality you can go all the way up to / 9
if you want
now from now onwards we are going to
step-by-step increase the complexity of
migrations let's look at traditional
data centers how traditional data
centers are visualized and then how the
cloud is visualized one by one step by
step in a traditional VC you can see
complex networking setup you have topic
rack switches you have closed networks
for high cross sectional bandwidth from
server to server you have to design with
or subscription different different
buffer ratios or whatnot
and then you have an aggregation layer
where you combine multiple such clusters
and export services out to the Internet
then you have a DMZ perimeter to come
create all the security rules you buy
some boxes from different vendors you
buy different boxes for the load
balancers you attach the load balancers
and security Ackles there some of them
are l2 some of them are l3 I think you
have to translate the VLAN Shin to l3 or
so many things you are doing the
traditional LOM 3-1 in cloud everything
is gone you have a UI in front of you
everything is consistent everything is
done for you behind us is universe JP
eyes click on few buttons all of these
things will be migrator so you don't
have to think about no more closed
networks no more these top of rack
switches everything is perceived from
the perspective of your services and
virtual machines all you have to think
about it I have a set of VMs think that
these beams are all connected together
now connected in a full mesh you get
like more than 10 Gbps of VM to VM
throughput and 100 microseconds of
latency why do you care about their
networks anymore you don't need to worry
about closed networks just create a
bunch of sad networks put the Williams
in the sub networks TM have web servers
I created a sub Network for web servers
I created a VM for application servers
through bran flakes and then I bought
some storage maybe Google Cloud storage
and I have a bigquery attached to it
another button click on some buttons you
create a load balancer single whip done
so no more thinking in the perspective
of complex networking terminology
anymore everything is through REST API
is behind the scenes Google takes care
of all the migration for you from now
aniss is going to talk about service
model and very specific use cases the
batch use cases web servers application
use cases thank you very much
hello everyone it is really great to be
here today
it is such exciting times for us and as
you heard Sylvia saying we've been
really really busy so hopefully you're
going to be as excited as we are on what
we are delivering to you in terms of
capabilities and I want to start by
recap you know what's why I said because
it's really important as the foundation
of what we do so there's three things
that he pick up on those are network
performance first and all the work that
has been done in Google infrastructure
to get where we are today with powers
everything we do and it is really in our
DNA we talk about the global scope
Google is a global network and
everything we do it is in that spirit we
provide private connectivity globally
and then we give you the flexibility to
then choose whether you want the
granularity to build regionally and have
the flexibility of communication within
the scopes that you need then the third
thing is everything as a service
everything meaning networking functions
in this case so that we are really
providing the level of a structures that
you need so you can map your services
and we'll take care of the rest for you
so having said that what I want to talk
to you about is how do you use those
capabilities for what you need for
bringing your services to the cloud and
mapping them flexibly the first way I
find useful are thinking about this is
about the services what the service
needs and that's going to that is going
to somehow determine what are the time
the type of capabilities that you'll
need in our Google cloud and during good
hands we can cover a lot of different
models you can have services that are
latency sensitive so they need to be
third flow
Klee and you need to be close to the
user for low latency you can have
services that require failure isolation
and you need to be conscious about your
failure domains and how you build
geographically as well and in which
scopes your services to provide that
redundancy replication may want to have
global replication for services like
databases and then security and privacy
very important who has permissions to
the work and how services can
communicate with each other
so if you think about what the services
need I think you can then have this
model on what you need in the network so
services we provide templates service
identities so that you can build your
services with policies with recipes that
you can replicate you can automate and
you can scale with the requirements of
the group in it comes the network built
well the beautiful network grouping and
the sub networks grouping do you need
global communication you can bring
Network global scope and build the
granularity of what you need with some
networks configuring your CIDR grouping
so that they can communicate as you need
so for data locality you can build your
sub networks originally and then you can
communicate globally if you need things
like data replication or a service that
is consuming from policies that are
distributed all over the world and of
course then all these maps into
geography so what is the failure domains
that you need what is the availability
that you need and then you can come up
with your strategy on how to map those
into the different zones regions that we
provide and then on top of all this it
comes the organization and again is who
has the control to the world
and this is very important so that there
is autonomy for the services to operate
and set up policies but at the same time
there is a framework for network
administrator and for sake ups to be
setting the rules that are going to that
need to be confirm with your de
infrastructure so very practically you
will define your services a policy based
on templates and then based on the
regional mapping on data locality that
you need you can choose to use sub
networks and based on the needs for
global communication you can use global
networks and then you can apply policy
to those and those are security glues
for firewall rules that govern how those
services can communicate and on top of
that you have the organization and the
control I'm going to spend a little bit
of time going through a couple of use
cases that I think it reflect some of
these mapping and capabilities that you
may find useful in our network
infrastructure for mobile serving it is
important to serve close to the user so
again they tell locality the services
closest to the user as as possible you
can have the service replicated in
different regions you can in the
migration scenario you can get access to
the cloud scale and at the same time if
you are thinking of expanding you have
access to the data locations and the
regions that we provide you may have an
owner for those services that is
separate from the service of for
instance the data processing and you
have a going to break some news here
global LV so it is going to be a single
bit that is going to be using used for
all the traffic but again serving today
from the closest location
and you can have a data processing that
is again a different owner and you have
the capabilities of using the
permissions and control to separate
those well allowing the communication I
think we've talked about a lot of the
capabilities of load balancing but it's
important the global scope a single bit
serving globally without DNS the
scalability and auto scaling and the
performance that comes along with that
let's go through another scenario and I
want to emphasize here certain things in
our capabilities an example of
centralized butts processing so you have
localized databases and in this case
it's a very simple inventory scenario in
which you may have databases in
different regions where you keep your
data for all the inventory of your
business but then you have another
different organization that is an audit
service and it's going to perform the
processing queries on what's the status
of the database it's under decentralized
it is a single unit that it needs to
maybe for compliance reasons fine what
is the status of those and you're going
to have different owners so what do you
do you will need a global network
because those services will need to
communicate with each other and publish
the data to a central location that is
going to do the data processing we will
need as well some locality the databases
are not located are located spread
around the world but they are group in
the different regions so we will need to
have the granularity of that
segmentation in the regions and you can
set the policies there you can assign
the CID arranges to map those region
segments into your CID ours
and then you'll have a net ops
administrator that is going to take the
responsibility of setting that up for
the whole organization you're set in the
database you have an owner for that
database and will be responsible of
configuring the service administering
that service you will use automated
templates like deployment manager cloud
launcher and you just kind of spin the
services very easy with a click then you
have a centralized let's say in this
case data prog magnets Hadoop is Park
and that's going to be central so this
is the audit that is going to be
processing the data for the compliance
of the the daytime they inventory you
need to set up firewalls thus a cops is
going to set the policies on each of
those services and subnet words and
decide how they are going to communicate
with each other and then data can be
published to a centralized location and
you could use pops up and then just the
private the scope communication is going
to allow you to do that seamlessly
without having to do any type of
additional mechanisms to privately
connect those regions so again there is
important aspects here about a private
global communication the control of the
users that are going to be set in the
different services the segmentation
policies that are going to be applied to
the network to the sub network or to the
BM level granularly and again everything
that powers our network is with high
performance in scaling in throughput and
in low latency with that I really thank
you all for being here and I'm going to
welcome Amit Singhal who's a tech lead
who's going to be talking about hybrid
scenarios
thanks anus hello everyone it's my
pleasure to be here so today I'll talk
about hybrid clouds and how Google
managed services really make it simple
and easy to provision them so hybrid
cloud is an essential part of the Strad
my Gration strategy for any enterprise
most enterprises have invested in some
way in their own premises traditional
data center or building their private
clouds so they want to leverage their
existing investment in private cloud or
the data center and so they want to
continue to host static core components
there and extend on-premises for growth
in public cloud and our services that
require rapid scaling into public cloud
and this also allows them to do phase
migration into public cloud while
they're evaluating various components of
it so now we will go into some common
scenarios that use hybrid cloud and I'll
go in-depth into one of them to show how
manage services like cloud VPN and cloud
router make it really simple to
provision hybrid roles so in this first
scenario there's an enterprise who has
set up their private cloud to host their
web services and they want to keep it
that way but now they have a need for
analytics and log processing and they
don't have a great infrastructure for
that in the private cloud so they decide
to use GCP for that so they spin off a
managed Hadoop service into public cloud
and to feed data from on-premises to
this managed to dupe service they need a
secure connection and cloud VPN service
makes it really simple to provision that
now I'd move on to second scenario it's
hypothetical setup from e-commerce
and price and they have their
traditional data center but they have
set up their web services into GCP
because they want to leverage
auto-scaling but in the data center they
have customers sensitive payment
information so they want to run their
payment processing application from
on-premises in addition they also have
their IT corporate in on-premises and
also employee subnets on premises so
again they want to secure connection TCP
and they use cloud VPN for it now let's
go a little more in depth into cloud VPN
service so cloud droopiness
it provides IPSec tunnel it supports
both I question v1 and v2
it also supports both global and
regional model so currently I show here
that there's a VPN connection only in
one region and it is used from both
regions but now customer can choose to
spin off another VPN in another region
and using that they can that allows for
traffic to egress and ingress locally
and cloud loopiness a completely managed
service it all you need to give is
public IP on both peers and the shared
secret password and that's it
so it supports high throughput up to one
point five gigabit per second on a
single tunnel and we also support like
horizontal scaling so you can start like
multiple VPN tunnels from a single
region now this sets up a VPN tunnel but
you also require routing to be set up on
both ends for traffic to go over VPN
tunnel and one way to do that is using
static routes so this is a good option
for
networks which are small and like
relatively static so now we'll go into
some scenarios where networks are
changing dynamically and they're they
change frequently and we'll see like how
we can use other managed services to
make it easy to provision so in this
scenario I'm showing that now customers
web service traffic is increasing in one
of the regions so it's scaling up and
subnet size is drawing next I teaspoons
of a corporate app in GCP and then in
on-premises one of the employee subnets
is divided into two for isolation
reasons so now with all these changes
happening if you don't want to intervene
manually every time and reconfigured
static crowds what you can do is like
start a cloud router cloud outer runs
BGP protocol to autodiscover network
changes on either side of your network
and you need you can start one cloud or
cloud outer in every region you have VPN
and it's also completely managed service
it pairs with bgp router on-premises and
it advertises all subnets of the region
to on-premises and all you need to do is
like select dynamic routing when you are
configuring your VPN and for b2b peering
we use link local IP addresses and this
also helps in preventing any conflict
with other private address space you
have on either side of your network for
a sense you configure a private a Centon
GCP for on-premises you can give your
publication or use a private a send and
that's all you need to do to configure
cloud router now I'll talk about some of
the advanced features of cloud router
which allow for high availability in
failure scenarios
cloud order supports graceful restart
feature what that means is that if your
bgp service on-premises goes down for
any reason cloud water will preserve
routes learn from on-premises for up to
three minutes and your traffic will not
be disrupted it will still continue to
flow of a pill tunnel
it also supports ecmp so now if you have
multiple talents from a region and
they're all noun syncs same BGP routes
and so that will allow the distribute
traffic equally among all the tunnels
another useful feature is to configure
multiple tunnels in a primary backup
mode and how it does is that if BGP on
this analysis announcing same routes but
with different properties then based on
the value of this properties one term
will be configured primary and other can
be backup and the properties we use is
med value is path length s prepend so
now if like one tunnel goes down the
other takes over and this is really fast
because the backup table was already pre
provision and it can just take over
immediately so now we have seen that how
Google managed services like cloud
router cloud VPN make it really simple
to provision a secure connection to GCP
with Auto discoverable networks now to
conclude this talk I will recap why GCP
so first and foremost it's about network
performance GCP delivers high throughput
and low latency it is highly scalable
reliable and always available it
provides global network with virtual
private networks that span globally
across all regions and last but not the
least it provides managed services like
big cloud VPN cloud router cloud DNS and
many more as virtualized network
functions for high scalability and
availability so with that I conclude
this talk
thank you